الاشياء التي حرمت منها وانت صغيره ابرزها
التعليم اا في مبادراتك كلها هي من اجل او
كثير منها من اجل
المساعده في موضوع التعليم حدثينا عنها
قليلا لو سمحت
طفوله في فيتنام بالالام والمشاعر الفيضان
نحو الاطفال لكن كله تلك المشاعر والالام
عادت من جديد مؤخرا في الحرب على اوكرانيا
وقد شعرت بسعاده غامره جدا للفرصه التي
اتيحك بزيارتين الاولى الى صوفيا في
بولندا والاخرى الى اوروبا لمرافقه لاجئين
الاوكرانيين الى كندا لقد كنت من يقف في
مدخل الطائره للترحيب بهم وهم يدخلونها
فرارا من الحرب لكنني كنت على وشك انهيار
كل ما ارى رضيعا او طفلا صغيرا مع والديه
لاجئين وهو يدخل الطائره كانوا اطفال صغار
وبناته كان يتعاين عليه ان احبس الى انني
مررت بنفسي ما مر به الفرار من الفوضى
والحرب لكنني الان في موقع يسمح لي بمنحه
من امل هذا جزء من مبادرتي لقد كنت احرص
على ان اقول لهم لا تستسلموا ولا تتخلوا
عن الامل فالناس تحبكم لقد كان الامر صعبا
جدا عليه لكن مع ذلك اعتقد ان لديهم
الفرصه للحصول على الحريه والاعاده بناء
حياتهم في زمن صعب جدا يعني هناك اناس
يعطوا فرص ثانيه في الحياه همم هل تعتبرين
نفسك كنت محظوظه لانك يعني واحده من بين
الارقام اختلفت الحقيقه تنام عدد الضحايا
من الاطراف المختلفه البعض يتحدث عن اكثر
من مليون ضحي ضحيه هل تعتبرين نفسك محظوظه
بانك انا جيتي بهذا الشكل
اه
نعم انا اكثر من محظوظه شعرت بانني مباركه
لاستمرار على قيد الحياه بالنسبه لما مررت
به والحصول على فرصه حياه اخرى واكثر من
هذا انني لا اعيش باعتباري احدى ضحايا
الحروب بل انني اصبحت رمزا للامل واتعلم
دروس المغفره والعفو والتجاوز والمحبه
واعطي المثل لهم لانني كنت مثلهم والان
كما اوضحت ذلك فانني تحاولت من صوره
الضحيه الى صوره الامل